[Musique]
bonjour bonjour ma était une fois plus
de la pression que vous avez réuni là
beaucoup de très beaux produits les
produits variés il ya toutes sortes de
choses et puis des liquides aussi
plusieurs liquide tout à fait différent
les années ce qu'est ce que vous mijoter
dans votre tête qu'est ce que vous allez
nous faire
eh bien on va faire une terrine de boeuf
à la bière c'est un clin d'oeil à nous
j'ai fait un gros bisou parce qu'ils
sont ils regardent très certainement
et puis quoi d'autre une terrible et une
tour peu pardon on la perd mme une
terrine de boeuf une tourner la page
ne confondons pas par contre pour les
produits on va peut-être dire tout d'un
coup et puis on suivra après encore une
sur cette voie là alors il faudra bien
entendu cela est excellente
celle là il faut de l'armagnac il faut
bon bon bon bon bon bon verre il faut du
poireau il faut des carottes
nous on a mis des chanterelles mais
pouvait faire de diverses façons de vous
faire revenir c'est parce que des
des girolles avec tout ce que vous
voudrez comme s'habillant nous on a ça
alors on fait ça fait avec les moyens de
bord commandes et on est gâté parce
qu'il y en ait très gâté parce que c'est
très frais et puis alors là vous avez
des pois chiches à cette jolie du la
paire bon la perte des oeufs du persil
de la ventrèche bien entendu d'autres
ventrèche il faut de la iihf de
l'hogneau il faut bon morceau de boeuf
mais quand 20 h et après et des 40 je
sais pas si je les ai dit voilà et la
gemmi de l'estragon
j'ai cru que vous alliez l'oubli je
n'oublie pas non et bien il avait
d'ailleurs été très bien c'est
d'estragon frais excellent et alors par
quoi avez vous l'intention de commencer
par la terrine vous avez fait réduire
des oignons là ils sont bien fondus un
petit peu d'eau rayon beaux ils vous
plaisent comme ça très bien qu'est ce
que vous y ajoutez alors les carottes
que je coupe un bordel tout simplement
tous afghans faudra du temps pour les
cuivres quand même c'est assez long non
je vais te tuer parce que j'ai regardé
le jeudi afin de boire c'est vite occupé
le vois bien pendant le goût de la voilà
jean m 2
et voilà il faudra ajouter quelque chose
avec quoi il parle l'aïe
mais je l'aimé trop d'ail écrasées par
les gaz et à la main comme nous fait
d'habitude
voilà bien signaux rondelle alors
maintenant la gousse d'ail du sel du
poivre et on va s'appuyer de taille
voilà saler poivrer et on va s'occuper
de la viande maintenant c'est à dire
qu'on annonce qu'il prendra du temps
quand même pour que ça aille doucement
que ça brûle pas oui maintenant et on va
assez la viande dans largement le temps
est encore h vous la coupe et voilà sous
là pour que cela passe y ait la moindre
valeur chez iw et la donnez moi tous
arts les y voilà bientôt ça va être pas
dur je crois pas si et des peintures
salle de soin vous en préparer pas mal à
vous avez l'intention de faire une
grosse mais vous allez voir il une fois
que ce sera cuit sera diminuée que vous
croyez beaucoup de légumes et bien sûr
qu'on ça y est vous pourrez tout me
donner allons-y gaiement
voilà l orange passe ça vous fait quoi
maintenant à gb2 la chauffer ça
déclarait à bouillir même et je vais
faire et pire les pois chiches en
voudrait les faire tremper très
longtemps alors l endroit
et puis il faut surtout qu'ils cuisent
très longtemps alors vous voulez mais
très bien le matin puis voilà
elle et sa livre dont vous n'avez pas
bien entendu bon et alors il devra
patienter le temps que sa cuisse des
légumes ils vont bien et alors là qu'est
ce que vous faites de ça mais on va
continuer j'ai fini - 2 alors je vais
prendre cette viande qui est très jolie
je vous ferai remarquer bien sûr et bien
hsc bien là et puis ne restera plus qu'à
mélanger le tout vous allez voir les
pois chiches maïté sont comme il faut
superbe est basiquement ils ont bien
profité quand vous viendrez à bordeaux
hazard bien enflée mais oui ils ont
triplé de volume un peu procédure est
passé bien à la moulinette une jolie
petite fille je comprends de purée et
pendant ce temps qu'est ce que vous
allez faire vous je m'amuse de comme une
petite folle voile et je dois vous salle
et généreusement
vous pouvez vrai voilà alors la viande
hachée je suis même mes légumes
oui je vais mélanger le tout il va
falloir en mettre un petit peu plus je
pense
le broc chiche je veux bien voilà vous
en prie vielles vous voyez bien que les
dossiers à l'économie seco
il y en a c'est yann à ces nouveaux
foyers
il y en a c'est merci parce que quand
même il faut les nourrir mais pas les
agresser voilà et blanc remuant mais
l'enjeu va falloir mouiller avec quelque
chose quand même parce que ça me paraît
bien cette année là j'ai d'abord évacuer
les humains que le père sylvain que
l'armagnac
ah voila voila merci pour commencer ou
wav pour commencer persifle le persil
des petites peluches qu'on va couper
grossièrement voilà tout simplement
comme ça
oui parce que ça va se mélanger
s'accusant ça va se mélanger voilà oui
ensuite j'allais faire un petit trou
pour mettre vos yeux là au milieu réseau
routier là je remets l'ange encore une
fois c'est quand même pas une cuisine
très compliqué a fait un faux pas
accompli que nous après ça vous allez me
demander de l'armagnac ceci s'il allait
givet où italease à soupe soin de creeps
hier il faut ce qu'il faut
j'y vais y aller mais on y parlera des
oui la veille voilà c'est bon ça va un
petit peu dans ce coin là vous faire
plaisir
top c'est bob faut pas quand même
exagéré pour aller là bas il ya aura du
gouffre mais ces savants se sont ensuite
alors pour le pire
je vais beuvry de plats qui se trouve là
mais je mélange encore un peu le trou
est de relier très bien là bien beurré
ce petit plat de tous les côtés
naturellement on allumer le four avant
parce qu'il faut qu'il soit bien chaud
voilà alors il reste un petit peu mais
ça n'a pas gâché ses bons moyens dont
vous voulez une cuillère plutôt que la
fourchette pour des moyens oui avec ses
petits pois cassés tel buzz trois
chiffres
c'est au petit pois cassés ouais non
nous ne confondons pas chiche fois ils
ont disparu dix ans on les voit plus
comme il était en plus rien et on met ce
qu'une jolie terrine voilà oui aux biens
je vais la recouvrir avec du papier
aluminium
oui là et vous allez me fasse et le plat
que vous avez à côté parce que vous avez
envie de m'attarder marie aubert mari ou
quatre fois ci c'est claude renard à
s'assurer profit mais bien sûr on était
là c'est un peu chez séché et ça à four
moyen il faut louis tout doucement et
maxence est chaud et il faudra combien
de temps votre avis moins d'une heure un
surnom 45 minutes
si on aime la viande 96,5 on sèche 45
minutes et on vous présentera le plan
and l'élite et parce qu'on aura encore à
faire une petite sauce à la bière la
sauce à la bière
que faites-vous maintenant maïté alors
je prends mes champignons chanterelles
dit j'ai fait dorer vd omnium voilà je
les mets dedans tout tout seul la foudre
a diminué à l'opinion oui bien sûr il
faut assez salé poivré et que vous avez
dit on aurait pu prendre d'autres
champignons des champignons de paris si
on est en ville mais là au nord de la
vienne on a la chance d'avoir des
champignons des bois bien sûr c'est
mieux alors des chanterelles et ensuite
quelques heures je vais préparer ma
sauce la sauce à la bière là lorsque
vous mettez là dedans je mets dans ma
casserole d'eau et on va faire ça comme
ce que faisait yves bicharel arribart à
vue de m
dans le détail surtout pas devait
surtout pas faire brûler le beurre non
plus et attention la vacance allait bien
chaude la vie
chaude alors je vais mettre dans ce
beurre fondu de la farine un petit peu
de farine vous aller embêter sur le feu
bien entendu je vais cuir ma farine aux
allées me prêter la bière ensemble à
prêter je voulais donner là vous allez
même écoulé un petit peu vers celle d'un
petit peu dessus des champs elysées et
j'y vais doucement largement parce que
le vois pas ce que ça va faire les vues
montre non un peu plus la regarder masse
associées joly donc quand je continue et
envahir ajouterait un petit peu de
bouillon dans la jv pour le bouillon
aucun petit peu de liberté voilà ensuite
on avait un bon bouillon vous avez fait
comme toujours avec de la viande de
boeuf de veau de port d'où les légumes
givet alors vous lui mettez et c'est bon
l'invité avec tout ça je suis pas
absolument sûr qu'on est en quarts la
seconde recette qu'on avait prévu vers
la tourte aux lapins on offre une autre
fois ce sera pour une autre fois
là il faut bien laisser cuire notre
sauce et puis ensuite vous avez le
montre et je crois qu'il va falloir
verser ça dans les champignons quand on
voit le tout les chanterelles ont bien
réduit là elles sont tout à fait à celle
qu'est ce que vous faites maintenant
levé a ajouté ma sauce sauf elle
habillait sens à l'avenir qui est
pratiquement pour une béchamel liquide
va pas trop liquide mais pas trop
épaisses non plus c'est bon voilà je
vais m cette fois je vais venir la wii
alessi et la verser dans la jatte
regardez moi ça c'est cet appétissant et
jolin
alors on avait sorti notre terrine qui a
évidemment changé passablement d'un
spiral elle vous paraît bien elle me
paraît bien est-ce que vous allez
prendre le risque de découper en
tranches
il faut toujours prendre des risques on
a remédié nous
il faut toujours prendre à défaut se
permettre et c'est un plaisir alors
allons-y voir annoncer à surprises on
avoir très bien travaillé leur sueur
mais évidemment mais évidemment ya pas
de raison et il y un peu les doigts
personne ne vous en voudra mais ici pas
mal
voilà un parent et même très bien
mais bien sûr bon et alors là vous allez
ctaq à l'arrêt ou accompagné avec un peu
de sauce nom des champignons tout c'est
un petit peu juste voie grecque ils sont
très bons on vous avait ouvert la
terrine france à côté vie en vous
mangerez en prenant la sauce des
champignons à côté regardez ça voilà je
trouve maïté que c'est très appétissant
sarah très joli alors si vous voulez
essayer comme vous avez vu suis pas très
difficile ça bien en avantage c'est
qu'on peut quand même préparer la
terrine un peu à l'avant mieux elle se
garde
et puis ensuite les champignons au
dernier moment ses travers et comment on
vous l'a dit n'importe quel champignons
de bons champignons bien frais alors
vous vous en donnerai des nouvelles si
vous avez essayé bientôt au revoir et on
vous dit bon appétit et à bientôt
[Musique]